Oh
so there's an amazing philosopher called
Eliades
who wrote a book about shamanism where
he spoke of psychedelic drugs as
technologies of ecstasy notice that he
uses the term technologies here he talks
about them as mankind's cognitive
toolkit agents of psychic transformation
we've been engaging in for tens of
thousands of years to transform the
perceptions of the body mind packing our
awareness and our perceptions you know
that evanescent flux of sensation and
perception that is in a way all we have
and all we are as Eric Davis says the
voice in your head that lets you know
that you exist these psychedelic agents
these meme mutagens essentially cause
mutation and ideation and our ideas and
I think that the term technologies of
ecstasy points to the fact that there is
something that happens in that ecstatic
place of ego death that resets the self
that gives us temporary access that
makes us privy to a whole host of new
wild visions that transform the way we
see the world and I think today these
modern digital shamans these ecstatic
technicians of the sacred these doctors
of the word are the scientists and
philosophers and riders that are there
making us question our current belief
systems and deconditioning our thinking
and that has always been the role of the
shaman to unplug us and to show us a
bigger wider more far-reaching universe
that goes beyond what the eye can see
or something like that